d'abord merci d'avoir pour les uns et
les autres accepté notre invitation je
voudrais d'abord vous commencer par vous
souhaiter une bonne année que c'est la
période donc on la souhaite évidemment
la plus calme possible même si
malheureusement je suis pas sûr que ces
souhaits soient exaucés euh et en tout
cas la la meilleure pour vous et ceux
qui vous sont
proches donc nous avons souhaité avec
Olivier sigigolotti Renant legleu et
Jean-Marc
vessousfort faire un conférence de
presse de de contte-rendu de de notre
déplacement en Ukraine qui s'est déroulé
euh à la fin du mois de de décembre nous
sommes revenus d'Ukraine le le 22
décembre donc on a voulu faire cette
visite d'abord dans cette période de de
Noël c'était important de de marquer
notre notre soutien à l'Ukraine la
situation est évidemment difficile le
front Est est gelé il y a un
essoufflement certain de l'aide
occidentale euh et puis euh un maintien
de la la pression russe qui est assez
assez évident avec une situation qui
devient de plus en plus compliquée
euh les médias ont souvent évoqué une
fatigue de la guerre d'Ukraine dans les
opinions publiques mais aussi euh
j'allais dire dans malheureusement dans
les dans les acteurs de la guerre en
Ukraine on l'a constaté euh une durée de
guerre bientôt de de 2 ans donc j' on a
parfois fait la comparaison avec la
guerre de 14 1916 l'usure la
fatigue le moral qui est pas forcément
au beau fix et et évidemment la
nécessité d'avoir une aide extérieure
pour pouvoir passer ce cap et puis un
relatif échec de la de la
contreoffensive
ukrainienne qui qui évidemment n'a
échappé à personne et bien entendu et je
pense que ça fait largement partie de
notre volonté d'aller en Ukraine la
crise au Proche-Orient qui a un peu fait
oublier euh la guerre en Ukraine puisque
depuis le 7 octobre une actualité en
chassant une autre et c'est pas avoue
que je vais l' prendre euh on a beaucoup
moins parlé de cette de cette
problématique majeure ukrainienne et
donc on a voulu avec mes collègues en en
se déplaçant en Ukraine
euh à notre modeste niveau euh iessayer
de remettre un petit peu ce sujet sur le
haut de la sur le haut de la pile et
rappeler à l'opinion publique évidemment
tout l'intérêt qu'il y avait à à
soutenir les Ukrainiens
euh parce que évidemment euh euh parce
que l'avenir de l'Europe évidemment est
extrêmement lié aujourd'hui à à ce qui
se passera
demain en
Ukraine parce que d'abord nous
considérons et nous l'avons écrit dans
le rapport que le projet de Poutine
n'est pas un projet de conquête
territoriale c'est sans doute aussi un
combat de valeur qu'il faut qu'il faut
mener parce que on peut ou pas avoir
cette conviction mais bonjour mais on
considère que si demain Poutine devait
gagner en Ukraine il est absolument pas
certain qu'il s'arrêtera là là ce qui
sera imposé c'est la p la paix des la
paix des gagnants la paix des vainqueurs
et que comme nous l'ONS dit assez
régulièrement d'ailleurs les Polonais
chez qui nous sommes allés les pays
baltes la Moldavie et autres
euh pourquoi s'arrêter
là donc notre idée c'était vraiment de
remettre ce sujet sur le haut de la pile
euh et de faire comprendre aussi à nos
opinions publiques que pour l'instant ce
sont les Ukrainiens qui se battent pour
nous et qui si demain euh
Poutine devait gagner et que on ne
s'arrêterait on ne s'arrêtait pas là ce
serait nous qui serions les suivants sur
euh la ligne de front entre guillemets
je dis pas la France en particulier mais
en tout cas les pays européens les pays
baltes la Moldavie et d'autres qui
serait évidemment les victimes d'une
volonté de reconstitution d'Empire que
met en œuvre Vladimir Poutine depuis
quelques temps voilà donc on a ciblé un
certain nombre de choses et on a fait
des recommandations dans ce rapport euh
on a notamment largement ciblé les les
les besoins les besoins Ukrainiens on a
eu des rencontres à haut niveau on a
rencontré le ministre des Affaires de de
la défense pardon qui d'ailleurs est à
Paris ces jour-ci on a rencontré le le
le directeur du renseignement militaire
qui est sans doute une des personnes les
plus compliquées à pouvoir rencontrer on
l'a rencontré dans des conditions un peu
un peu rambolaisque on va dire mais en
tout cas on l'a rencontré ça été aussi
très intéressant et ça a été aussi un
moment qui a permis au
au aux Français présents sur le terrain
de enfin sur le terrain sur président à
Kief ne nous trompons pas sur ce que je
veux dire présent à Kief notamment les
les corps diplomatiques bien de pouvoir
voilà avoir des information
complémentairire parce qu'il y avait a
priori un certain temps qu'ils avaient
pas pu le qu'il n'avaient pas pu le
rencontrer donc euh la présence je pense
de parlementaires sur des missions comme
celle-là c'est aussi euh c'est aussi de
la diplomatie parlementaire et la
diplomatie parlementaire ça permet aussi
d'ouvrir des portes
que parfois nos services diplomatiques
nos services militaires ou nos
industriels ne peuvent pas ouvrir à eux
seuls donc la
présence la présence de de de de de
parlementair c'est je pense en tout cas
important c'est en tout cas largement
reconnu par nos ambassades dans les
différents pays dans lesquels on va
j'étais encore il y a pas très longtemps
en Colombie à Expo des fin de ça et ça a
permis aux industriels de rencontrer
ministre de la Défense que enfin je
parle en toute modestie mais ce que N
n'aurait pas d faire si nous n'avions
pas été présents donc je pense que cette
diplomatie parlentaire que qui est
souhaitée par le président Larcher euh
et qu'on sur laquelle on on on met on
fait beaucoup d'efforts est une est une
une nécessité donc sur les Ukrainiens
les Ukrainiens sur les besoins qu'ils
ont exprimés évidemment d'abord des
munitions
euh l'idée qui est affirmée enfin qui
est avancée c'est que il y a environ
entre 5 et 8000 tir coup qui sont tirés
quotidiennement par les ukrainiens et
sans doute peut-être pas le double mais
entre entre 10 et 10 et 10 et 15000 par
les Russes quotidiennement euh et
que je pense que c'est à aller jusqu'à
30000 coups par jour quand on sait
évidemment que nous sommes aujourd'hui
en capacité en France de produire et ça
a été dit donc je veux pas ne défleur
aucun sujet ça a été dit dans le cadre
de la discussion sur la loi de Programm
la loi de finance dernièrement euh on
fabrique aujourd'hui 20000 obus de 155
par
an ça veut dire qu'en gros on fabrique
en un an euh le la consommation de 3 ou
4 jours de de de combat en Ukraine donc
il y a un besoin urgent de munition euh
et je le disais donc notre niveau de
production nationale reste extrêmement
faible tout comme d'ailleurs celui de la
production européenne puisque le le
l'ASAP enfin les projets qui ont été mis
en place au niveau européen notamment
par le commissaire breton et qui faisait
état d'un d'une livraison promise de 1
million de 1 million de munitions à à
l'Ukraine aujourd'hui est rempli à
hauteur de 300000 donc on a on a quand
même un vrai sujet de ce côté-là et donc
le message qu'on souhaite faire passer
en revenant de d'Ukraine c'est que c'est
maintenant qu'il faut agir en fait et
que c'est maintenant qu'il que l'Ukraine
a besoin de notre aide qu'elle a besoin
de notre soutien il y a évidemment
d'autres besoins qui ont été évoqués
notamment des missiles scalp des canons
César je tiens à signaler sur les canons
Césars et on l'a mis dans le rapport que
le le retour que nous avons eu d'abord
du ministre de la Défense en personne et
du directeur du renseignement militaire
également en person personne c'est que
le canon César est complètement en phase
avec ce qu'il recherche et que
contrairement à ce qui a pu être écrit
parfois dans la presse par des
témoignages de soldats Ukrainiens ou ou
je ne sais pas trop qui le le le canon
est extrêmement performant et et il
répond aux attentes c'est la raison pour
laquelle d'ailleurs ils aimeraient en
avoir en avoir
davantage il y a un problème évidemment
de disponibilité de défense solaire
également mais ça c'est depuis le départ
donc il y a des demandes qui sont faites
de ce de ce côté-là euh et puis on a
visité aussi un un un dispositif très
intéressant qui s'appelle brave one qui
est en fait un dispositif d'incubation
de start-up ukrainiennees qui sont
centralisés sur un site et qui donc font
de la de la recherche de l'innovation et
et des propositions de de matériel pour
les forces ukrainiennes et et donc on a
insisté très fortement sur la nécessaire
coopération industrielle qui peut y
avoir avec nos industriels parce que
nous avons évidemment euh la chance dans
notre beau pays la France d'avoir des
des compétences et les Ukrainiens aussi
mais ils ont aussi ils ont quelque chose
que nous n'avons pas c'est l'expertise
et l'expérience du terrain et le fait de
pouvoir travailler avec des industriels
français sur sur
euh l'expertise et et et et les besoins
concrets du terrain c'est évidemment
quelque chose
d'irremplaçable et donc nous avons aussi
largement insisté là-dessus et je pense
que
je je pense qu'on peut en parler mais
voilà il y aura d'ailleurs demain dans
le cadre de la visite du ministre de la
Défense
ukrainien des discussions avec des
industriels pour justement il faut
absolument qu'on multiplie les retours
d'expérience et qu'on multiplie les
relations qu'on peut mettre en œuvre
entre les industriels français et les
industriels Ukrainiens pour arriver à
travailler en bonne collaboration et
pour faire progresser nos matériels pour
faire progresser nos compétences et
notre grâce aussi à leur expertise euh
et puis faire progresser aussi leurs
compétences évidemment c'est une c'est
un travail
commun donc en fait il faut aussi qu'on
arrive à maintenir le sujet ukrainien
dans les la préoccupation de nos
compatriotes et dans le débat public
c'est pas c'est une une des missions
qu'on s'est qu'on s'est fixé avec mes
collègues mais c'est une mission
compliquée donc on a besoin évidemment
de la presse d'où aussi l'importance
pour nous de faire cette conférence de
presse
euh parce que cette guerre on l'a je
l'ai dit en préambule elle nous concerne
tous directement et ça je pense que
c'est quelque chose qu'on n pas
forcément complètement intégré
au niveau national et deuxième message
c'est qu'il faut évidemment changer
d'échelle sur les munitions il faut
changer maintenant voilà on a pas de on
a pas de délai pour
avancer on a beaucoup au Sénat remis en
cause à l'époque la question de
l'économie de guerre et moi le premier
d'ailleurs notamment dans le cadre de la
loi de programmation militaire à l'été
dernier pour dire en fait c'est bien de
parler d'économie de guerre mais
finalement qu'est-ce qu'on fait
concrètement pour que on soit réellement
dans une économie de guerre une économie
de guerre et ça suppose des réquisitions
ça suppose euh une augmentation de de de
de de de la cadence ça suppose des
réquisitions de personnel de
d'entreprise ce qui n'est évidemment pas
le cas en France et c'est pas ce qu'on
demande hein mais euh ça veut dire que
les mots ont un sens et qu'aujourd'hui
l'économie de guerre qu'on a mis en
place elle ne nous semble pas en tout
cas à la hauteur des attentes et je le
dis aussi souvent la France doit être un
allié exemplaire et un allié exemplaire
c'est un allié qui est en capacité euh
d'apporter une aide significative à ses
à ses alliés et aujourd'hui on apporte
une aide à l'Ukraine et ça a été salué
je tiens à le dire et à le redire ça a
été très largement salué par nos
différents interlocuteurs l'aide
française est est précieuse les AMX 10RC
les Césars les samt et cetera tout le
matériel qu'on fourn est un Forel de
qualité qui a son utilité et qui est
très apprécié mais euh on a bien bien
évidemment compris que compte tenu de de
l'urgence de la situation il faut qu'on
soit en capacité de de de redoubler
notre aides donc il y a évidemment
on est allé en Ukraine au moment où
l'aide européenne était quand même en
difficulté du fait de la des
atermoimements ou en tout cas des
oppositions de notamment
orbane donc il y a il y a vraiment une
urgence à à à aider
l'Ukraine les recommandations vous les
avez le rapport l'essentiel vous l'avez
ce que je vous propose c'est plutôt
parce que j'aimerais aussi que ce soit
interactif et que mes collègues puissent
apporter leur leur pierres à l'édifice
et leur leur expérience par que je suis
pas le seul à être allé en Ukraine que
je propose c'est que si vous avez des
questions nous y répondions mais je vais
pas développer davantage je pense que
vous avez des questions plutôt précises
donc Olivier Renand et et Jean-Marc et
moi-même son à votre disposition pour y
répondre merci beaucoup en tout
cas
bonjour pardon excusez-moi je regardis
mon papier bonjour Cécile Feuillat pour
la FP j'ai deux questions dans une
d'actualité le président Macron a
annoncé hier que la France allait livrer
40 scalpes si je me trompe et des
centaines de bombes euh est-ce que ça
vous paraît répondre aux attentes ça
c'est la première question et la
deuxième c'est sur les les besoins
qu'ont exprimé les partenaires
Ukrainiens est-ce qu'ils ont évoqué les
mirages
français répondre
je bon sur les munitions tout toutes les
annonces qui sont faites et qui
consistent à dire que on va livrer
davantage de munitions c'est des sont
des bonnes annonces la question c'est de
savoir quel est le le le le volume qui
est concerné 40 SC c'est une une bonne
nouvelle je pense qu'il y a des demandes
après euh il faut toujours mettre les
annonces en rapport avec la consommation
quotidienne euh et comme je je comme je
l'ai je l'ai dit aussi il faut être
prudent sur les annonces qu'on fait
parce qu'on on annonce des choses à un
pays en guerre qui est dans dans une
enfin qui a une forte attente sur les
annonces qu'on va lui faire donc les
annonces qu'on fait il faut qu'elles soi
concrètes qu'elle soit j'allais dire
sonnante et trébuchante c'est-à-dire
qu'il faut qu'elle soit
euh
h conclusive et qu'il soit mise en œuvre
merci euh donc la la la c'est bien
d'aller en Ukraine et de dire comme l'a
fait le ministre nouveau ministre des
Affaires étrangères que la priorité
ukrainienne demeure ça c'est une
excellente chose euh mais dire qu'il
faut redoubler d'efforts avant de
redoubler d'efforts il faut déjà qu'on
avant de les redoubler il faut déjà
arriver à à satisfaire les efforts
initiaux ceux qui ont été fait depuis le
début de la guerre or aujourd'hui
malheureusement je pense que le le le
même s'il a il y a beaucoup d'efforts
qui sont faits par les armées et par le
ministère pour fournir du matériel le le
compte n'y est pas et il faut qu'on
puisse être en capacité de de faire
davantage et c'est l'éternel problème de
la commande et et de la livraison
c'est-à-dire queon a beaucoup
d'industriels qui nous expliquent qui
pourrai peut-être pour fabriquer
davantage à la condition d'avoir des
commandes et on a d'un autre côté le
ministère qui nous explique lui que les
commandes sont faites donc on a on va
lancer une initiative à la Commission
dans les jours qui viennent et on va
lancer un cycle d'audition sur la
question des munitions pour faire
concrètement un peu le jour pour avoir
en tout cas une information beaucoup
plus complète sur ce qui nous est dit
par les uns et par les autres et pour
pouvoir avoir une opinion qui soit une
opinion plus claire parce qu'aujourd'hui
entre les industriels qui vous
expliquent qu' peuvent faire plus
peut-être plus euh mais qui n'ont pas de
commande et le ministère qui dit qu'il y
a des commandes parce queon a quand même
voté à la LPM 16 milliards donc c'est
pas une paille donc c'estes 16 milliards
il faut qu'on envoie maintenant la
couleur il faut que les commandes
arrivent et que les et que les
productions se fassent mais euh
un aster ça doit être 24 mois de
production donc quand on voit
qu'aujourd'hui les Russes ont
parfaitement compris qu'il qu'ils
allaient user entre guillemets no nos
matériels ou les matériels Ukrainiens
avec des des des tirs de quand on était
en Ukraine le mercredi où nous sommes
partis dans la nuit il y a eu une corp
de 35 drones sans doute des des cha
enfin drones low Iraniens qui ont été
envoyés sur l'Ukraine et notamment sur
keV il y en a 34 qui ont été interceptés
mais avec des missiles qui vaut qui
valent beaucoup beaucoup plus cher que
le que le que le drone j'imagine
donc je pense que c'est une bonne
nouvelle que d'annoncer qu'il y a des
missiles qui qu'il y a des missiles qui
vont être livrés je on doit le saluer
mais il faut mesurer après des centaines
vous avez dit que des des centaines de
missiles bb de bombes voilà si c'est des
centaines de deob de 155 il envole
environ 25000 par
jour sur l'Ukraine entre C entre les les
deux cobilés géants donc une centaine ça
veut rien diref il faut préciser les
choses et il faut qu'on soit clair et
que soit clair par rapport aux
Ukrainiens je pense qu'ils ont besoin de
ça sur les mirages pardon sur les
mirages j'ai pas d'éléments
je il y a des formations qui sont faites
il y a des choses mais on n pas eu de
demande particulière sur ce secteur on a
on a on va se dire les choses on a
quelques parlementaires de la commission
de la défense de la Rada qui nous ont
dit qu'il fallait absolument les
autoriser à les frapper sur le
territoire russe
moi je enfin on reste très prudent sur
ces questions parce que euh enfin vous
connaissez le sujet mieux que nous donc
moi je pense que c'est au militair de
dire ce qu'il est dans de droit de faire
ou pas et pas au et pas aux politiques
donc là-dessus moi je je suis très très
très prudent en revanche sur les avions
on on ne nous en a pas parlé
oui François d'ançon journaliste
indépendant deux questions euh comment
vous appréciez la formule utilisée par
le Président hier nous ne pouvons pas
laisser la Russie gagner en Ukraine nous
ne le devons pas est-ce que vous estimez
que c'est une bonne formule de dans vos
entretiens en
Ukraine est-ce que vous avez eu
l'impression que le disons le le focus
des Ukrainiens militaires serait dans
les mois qui
viennent la Crimée comme beaucoup
semblent encourager l'Ukraine à a ciblé
la Crimée comme moyen de pression ultime
sur Poutine est-ce que vous avez eu ce
sentiment au cours de vos
entretien alors sur je sais pas si
quelqu'un allis-y hein parce que moi je
suis pas de
problème sur la question qui concerne
les affirmations du président de la
République moi je peux que lui donner
raison à 300 % ce que je ne souhaite pas
c'est que ce soit in cantatoire et que
ce soi des affirmations qui ne soit que
de la communication enfin je évidemment
on ne peut pas laisser la l'Ukraine
perdre et on ne peut pas on ne doit pas
le faire mais encore faut-il lui donner
les moyens de de pouvoir poursuivre son
son j'allais dire son son son offensive
ou sa contreoffensive aujourd'hui les
positions sont en train de se geler on
on arrive dans une guerre de tranchée où
à à raison de de centaines d'hommes par
jour on ne conquiert quasiment aucune
aucune aucun territoire ou quelques
quelqu quelques dizaines de mètres donc
c'est une
une guerre d'usure euh dans laquelle la
vie humaine du côté russe n'a absolument
aucune valeur euh on nous a expliqué la
manière dont les les Cortes de
militaires russes allai au contact des
des des forces ukrainiennes pour jeis
dire je sais pas si c'est un peu brutal
mais pour pour pour leur faire pour leur
faire tirer des munitions enfin c'est
c'est absolument object et donc ils ont
besoin de de de ils ont besoin de
matériel donc nous ne pouvons pas et
nous ne devons pas les laisser perdre ça
c'est une évidence je pe on peut pas
dire le contraire pas les laisser perdre
ça veut dire ça veut pas forcément dire
qu'il qu'il gagn ça ça c'est un
autrere question sur la formule pr je
t'en prie je peux c'est pour ça que je
vous pose la question sur la formule
parce que le président n'a pas dit
permettre à à l'Ukraine de gagner il a
dit ne pas laisser la Russie gagner ce
qui n'est pas tout à fait la même
chose ça
suppose enfin en l'état actuel des
choses moi je reste persuadé que soit
soit ils gagnent soit ils perd enfin
tout dépend de ce que des négociation
territoriale qui pourrait être mise en
œuvre et tout dépend de ce qu'on de ce
que les ENF on va dire les choses ce que
les Américains entre guillemets
accepterait de leur laisser perdre ou
pas euh il y a il y a beaucoup de il y a
beaucoup de paramètres qui rentrent en
ligne de compte 20224 va être une année
évidemment très compliqué vous avz
évidemment il do pas échapper que aux
États-Unis ça allait être difficile et
que évidemment personne n aujourd'hui en
capacité de savoir ce qui va se passer
mais enfin euh ça prend pas une tournure
tout à fait dans la conforme à ce que
nous aimerion que qui se passe donc tout
dépend aussi de ce qui va être décidé à
ce niveau-là
euh moi je reste en tout cas les les
ceux que nous rencontrons sur place les
que soit des Ukrainiens les polonais ou
les pays baltes tous ceux qui sont en
fait à la
frontière russe euh vous explique très
clairement que si toutefois nous
laissons l'Ukraine perdre le terme est
clair perdre il est absolument pas exclu
que demain Poutine ne continue pas son
offensive d'ailleurs pourquoi est-ce
qu'il s'arrêterait puisqu'il a gagné
donc l'objectif je pense c'est d'essayer
de faire en sorte d'aider l'Ukraine pour
qu'elle
gagne ça c'est clair je pense he
j'imagine vas-y pardon je sur la
CR vas-y B jeen
prie sur votre deuxième question je
crois qu'il y a un message fort qu'on a
tous ressenti tous les quatre ressentis
c'est la volonté
inébranlable de l'Ukraine de recouvrir
ses frontières de
c'est l'objectif que nous avons ressenti
auprès de tous nos interlocuteurs sans
aucune exception aucune
exception c'est de reprendre la totalité
du territoire c'est-à-dire louansk
Donetsk le donbas la Crimée la totalité
les frontières de 91 et là-dessus il y a
une unanimité si vous voulez c'est c'est
quelque chose qui est un message très
fort que nous avons reçu on a quand même
rencontré beaucoup de monde pas que des
militaires des gens qui sont à la fois
sur les affaires étrangère même même
dans la même dans un dans les start-ups
si vous voulez on a vu des gens qui sont
dans le privé et cetera donc des gens
avec des profils différents il y a une
unanimité absolue sur cette question
retrouver l'intégralité l'intégrité
territorial de91 et donc si vous voulez
votre question la réponse elle est
claire euh il est pas question
d'abandonner le
donbas moi je vais vous faire par d'un
petite expérience personnelle depuis que
je suis bon ça fait 10 ans que je suis
2024 ça fera 10 ans que je suis sénateur
et depuis 2017 je suis à l'Assemblée
parlementaire de l'OTAN et j'ai été
pendant un temps pendant 3 ans
rapporteur rapporteur général de la
commission sécurité et défense de
l'Assemblée parlementaire de l'OTAN j'ai
commis un certain nombre de rapport sur
le sur la Russie notamment et sur
l'armement russe sur le budget de la
Défense russe et ce qui m'a permis de de
de de rencontrer beaucoup de mes
collègues des pays baltes notamment et
on les rencontre aussi évidemment dans
les dans les réunions plinières et
euh je crois que de 2017 à 2022 on on on
a on a cessé de leur dire qu'il fallait
qu'ils arrêtent d'être parano en fait
parce qu'ils nont jamais cessé à aucun
moment de nous dire que nous n'étions
pas suffisamment conscients euh du
danger et de la volonté en tout cas de
de de de Vladimir Poutine de
reconstituer cet empire perdu et moi le
premier je je le dis avec parce que je
je suis aussi capable d'introspection
moi le premier j'ai toujours considéré
qu'effectivement cette espèce de de de
paranoïa antirusse était sans doute lié
à 50 ans d'une histoire difficile et que
il fallait maintenant essayer de passer
à autre chose passer au dialogue et
qu'il y avait aucun risque et puis
finalement le 22 février 24 février4
février 2022
euh on s'est rendu compte que cette
paranoï elle était pas si infondé que ça
et je pense qu'on regarde ce conflit
avec nos
yeux
d'Européens de l'Ouest
euh avec un confort euh qui nous a été
permis grâce à euh une paix durable
depuis la fin de la deuxème guerre
mondiale euh on a on avait ce matin en
audition la la présidente du du du du
Parlement chipriote qui disait je suis
d'une génération qui considérait que la
paix était éternelle et qui allait pu
jamais y avoir de difficulté elle était
enseignante avant elle nous disit
j'enseignais à mes élèves que on allait
vivre des jours heureux et cetera bon
bah du jour au lendemain en une nuit
tout s'est effondré et on se rend compte
que finalement ces gens-là qui sont à
l'est et qui sont à la frontière n'étent
pas si naïf que si n'était pas n'était
pas si comment dirais loin de la de la
vérité que cela et donc aujourd'hui
quand on met quand ils nous mettent en
garde sur la volonté de Poutine de
reconstituer cet empire et donc d'aller
plus loin peut-être que que l'Ukraine si
toutefois il devait l'emporter en
Ukraine je pense qu'il faut le prendre
assez au sérieux après on peut
évidemment se tromper et ce serait
souhaitable mais euh le proverbe dit que
si tu veux si tu veux la paix il faut
préparer la guerre et ce que nous disons
nous au niveau national on l'a dit dans
le cadre de la LPM c'est qu'il faut
qu'on soit en capacité de d'abord d'être
un allié exemplaire d'être en capacité
donc de livrer du matériel mais pour
pouvoir livrer du matériel encore
faut-il en avoir et euh et de et de
d'avoir du matériel en nombre suffisant
c'est toute la l'opposition qui nous qui
nous qui nous enfin c'est tout ce qui
nous oppose avec le ministre des armées
sur le problématique de la masse puisque
c'est rappelez-vous dans le cadre de la
lo discussion sur la loi de
programmation militaire on a eu cette
discussion avec le ministre et il a ses
arguments nous on en avance d'autres et
je pense que la vérité est sans doute
entre les deux mais on on avait dit à
l'époque et c'était un peu provocateur
que la la disuasion nucléaire ne pouvait
pas être notre nouvelle ligne magino ce
qui a fait réagir très fortement
d'ailleurs et le ministère et et et et
quelques personnes mais c'était une
image qu'on voulait évidemment donner en
disant on peut pas euh baser la totalité
de notre défense sur la disuasion
nucléaire donc il faut qu'on ait aussi
de la masse voilà donc on on continue de
le penser mais c'est pas que de la masse
pour se défendre c'est aussi de la masse
pour être un allié exemplaire
oui bonjour Joh j'ai plusieurs questions
euh la première juste précision sur les
munitions 20000 par ans de 155 euh en
France mais ça c'était le chiffre qu'on
donnait il y a 2 ans déjà donc est-ce
que il y a eu il y a aucun progrès en
France sur sur ça c'est moins que ça
quand même ou on a progressé quand même
mais on a ça a progressé c'est une
évidence mais à notre goût évidemment
pas suffisamment d'accord et et quand on
parle au niveau européen donc là il y a
un manquement de 700000 sur les les 1
million pourquoi ce manquement est-ce
que ça c'est une question de production
dans ces pays ou est-ce qu'il y a
certains pays qui gardent gardent leur
stock et il partagent pas leur stock sur
le niveau européen est-ce qu'on a aussi
un problème maintenant avec la facilité
de paix EUR euréne et le blocage
essentiellement le blocage allemand
maintenant qui se dit ben ça vaut plus
la peine qu'est-ce que vous pensez de ce
qui se passe sur sur ça parce que les
Français sont assez pour la facilité de
pay et dernière question c'est c'est sur
Ben l'éventualité que si Trump
gagne est-ce que l'Europe commence à se
préparer pour cette éventualité sor
notamment sur le le sujet le dossier
ukrainien sur le dossier de facilité je
laisserai peut-être non répondre je vais
répondre sur les munitions moi sur les
munitions la conviction que j'ai c'est
que aujourd'hui on paye 30 40 ans de
désindustrialisation de ce pays euh
c'est le sénateur d'un département qui
est sans doute le département le plus
industrialisé de France qui vous le dit
euh on souffre de cela et on est on a
une certaine incapacité à remonter en
puissance euh il vous a pas échappé ou
peut-être que ça vous a échappé mais je
vais vous le rappeler qu'il y a un al je
sais pas s'il est délégué à à la
réindustrialisation au plan c'est ça un
commissaire à la réindustrialisation ça
vous a surtoute échappé parce que nous
on on sait pas où il habite il s'appelle
François berot euh alors je sais pas si
c'est un emploi semi fictif ou pas mais
euh en tout cas ce qui est clairire
c'est que il y a un vrai besoin de
réindustrialiser ce pays et je pense pas
qu'aujourd'hui on éite les moyens et sur
la question des munitions on est
exactement dans la même problématique
que sur le reste on a eu cette
problématique au moment du covid
rappelez-vous le dolipran les masques
quelle leçon est-ce qu'on en a tiré
c'est une question qu'il faut qu'on se
pose et aujourd'hui on a exactement
cette même problématique sur le sujet
des munitions parce que on a abandonné
un P entier de notre souveraineté en
considérant à l'époque que ces sujets
n'étaient pas des sujets hyper
stratégiques et souverains et que on
pouvait parfaitement aller acheter des
munitions à l'étranger ou que et ça
c'est une réponse que nous avait donné à
l'époque leedriant en 2016 je crois à la
Commission à une question que jeavais
posé qui avait dit ne vous inquiétez pas
on a des alliés et si toutefois euh on
devait être dans la difficulté nos
alliés nous fourniraient des munitions
sauf que les alliés sont comme tout le
monde quand ils ont besoin de munition
ils favorisent enfin en tout cas de
matériel de poudre de poudre propulsive
ou de poudre noire il favorisent d'abord
leur industrie et et après
éventuellement celle de leur clients
potentiel donc aujourd'hui on se
retrouve dans une situation où d'abord
on s'est largement je pense mis dans les
mains d'un certain nombre de pays qui ne
nous sont plus très favorables
aujourd'hui fa fabriquer du de la poudre
il faut de la potasse il faut des des
des acides il faut un certain nombre de
matériaux que dont on cellulau je crois
un certain nombre de matériaux dont on
ne dispose plus chez nous et donc une
chimie dont on ne dispose plus donc
qu'il y a eu évidemment une forte
volonté du ministre des armées
de reconstituer en tout cas ses
capacités notamment à Bergerac mais mais
ça prend du temps et donc on souffre
aujourd'hui d'une désindustrialisation
d'un point de vue militaire mais d'un
point de vue général et je pense que
pour aujourd'hui la fabrication des obus
de 155 puisqu'on était sur cette
question
euh on dépend de de de d'une capacité de
quelques machines donc une des questions
qu'on posera justement dans le cadre de
la mission enfin de la mission pas de la
mission mais du cycle d'audition qu'on
va mettre en place sur les munitions
c'est de savoir si aujourd'hui c'est
l'industriel qui n'est pas capable de
monter en cadence ou si c'est les
commandes qui ne sont pas suffisantes
pour que l'industriel monte en cadence
parce que c'est deux choses différentes
euh donc nous on voudrait élucider un
petit peu cette cette problématique ces
questions là mais en tout cas et c'est
une évidence absolue et c'est pas la la
faute de de ce gouvernement euh nous
souffrons d'une désindustrialisation qui
aujourd'hui nous pénalise une fois de
plus après le covid et bien c'est c'est
notre notre défense qui en qui en
souffre donc moi mon analyse elle est
enfin voilà en tout cas elle est assez
claire sur C cette question je te laisse
répondre peut-être sur puis après sur
l'élection potentielle de Donald Trump
évidemment ça a été évoqué par nos
interlocuteurs le déplacement était à
Varsovie et à Kief c'est vrai qu'aussi
bien à Varsovie qu'à Kief ça a été un
sujet qui a été abordé avec une pointe
de
fébrilité
néanmoins Trump a déjà eu 4 ans de
présidence et
entre des positions souvenez-vous lors
d'une interview il avait remis en cause
l'automaticité de l'article 5 du Traité
de l'Atlantique Nord et ce qui a
réellement été exécuté pendant les 4 ans
c'est-à-dire est-ce que véritablement il
y a eu des départs massifs de troupes
présentes en Allemagne qui est quand
même un pays où les contingents sont
absolument considérable en réalité non
c'estàdire que entre les discours de
Donald Trump et la réalisation on sent
qu'il y a une forme d'État profond
américain
prootanien qui a qui a a quand même euh
d'une certaine manière résisté et donc
c'est là où il faut probablement
euh prendre un peu de distance entre le
candidat en campagne et
l'exécution réelle de la politique du
potentiel président Trump lors d'un
deuxè mandat donc voilà on peut déjà
faire un bilan des 4 ans de la première
présidence Trump est-ce qu'il y a eu
véritablement une dé un départ massif
des des des GI sur le continent européen
il me semble que la réponse est non donc
en revanche il est vrai que les débats
budgétaires actuels avec les positions
des républicains américains euh ne sont
pas de nature à donner le
sentiment d'un engagement aussi fort que
les démocrates ça c'est clair et que ce
soit à Varsovie ou à Kief tout ça est
dans les radars c'est très
clair deux éléments complémentaires
peut-être pour apporter aux réponses de
de mes collègues euh lorsque nous étions
en Pologne nos interlocuteurs nous
disaient clairement et à plusieurs
reprises que l'année 2024 allait voir se
dérouler trois élections une en
Biélorussie une en Russie et une aux
États-Unis l'élection en Biélorussie en
Russie on en connaissait déjà le
résultat celle qui les inquiétait le
plus c'était bien sûr celle aux
États-Unis moi je vrais revenir
rapidement sur ce qu'évoque notre
président sur la désindustrialisé
les drones qui frappent quient
régulièrement mais aussi qui frappent
régulièrement les les plus grandes
villes dans les dans les oblastes de
l'Ouest sont des drones de fabrication
iranienne j'étais la semaine dernière au
Proche-Orient les drones qui frappent
les populations
israéliennes sont des drones de
fabrication israélienne le Hamas
iranienne pardon le Hamas et le
Hezbollah sont financés par l'Iran et
lorsque l'on parle des des
problématiques que de circulation de nos
navires de commerce en mer Rouge et bien
lorsqu'on parle des rebells outils ils
sont également armés par des drones
chahid qui veut dire martyr en arabe de
fabrication iranienne donc le le
dénominateur commun malgré tout entre
ces trois zones de conflit c'est quand
même l'Iran et notre président évoquit
la désindustrialisation des P européens
pendant ce temps l'Iran a poursuivi son
effort de de guerre a anticipé un
certain nombre d'éléments et et poursuit
ses efforts en matière de de nucléaire à
des fins que l'on connaît les uns et les
autres
oui juste deux sentiments que je crois
qu'on on partage collectivement les
premiers c'est que la situation elle est
critique pour les Ukrainiens en ce
moment et que la syymétrie est en train
de de d'augmenter encore il y a la
question on l'a dit des munitions et il
y a la question aussi de la défense
antiaérienne qui pourrait montrer demain
quelques quelques faiblesses donc si on
veut à un moment donné rétablir un petit
peu l'équilibre voire même avoir une
forme de de Game changer on va nous
solliciter sur du matériel de plus en
plus sophistiqué on nous a déjà fait
comprendre que le F16 tel qu'ils avaient
été fourni ne changerait pas la donne et
peut-être qu'effectivement on nous
sollicitera du matériel supplémentaire
parce que c'est des FC d'ancien de très
ancienne génération et deuxième élément
Rona a tout à fait raison on l'a
complètement partagé si certains
s'imaginent qu'il peut y avoir une une
forme de négociation avec une
répartition des territoires c'est
quelque chose que aujourd'hui nous on
exclut totalement pour avoir discuté
avec les ukrainien la question de la
Crimée effectivement pour eux
fondamentale on a un signe par exemple a
rencontré le le ministre de la défense
c'est un tatar de Crimée je n'imagine
pas une seconde qui puisse accepter de
rendre la Crimée aux Russes donc il y a
urgenence à agir on peut faire des
annonces mais derrière il faut qu'on
soit qu'on puisse répondre à ces
annonces là je pense qu'il n'est surtout
pas le temps de faire des promesses
qu'on ne pourrait pas tenir ça vaut pour
tout ça vaut aussi pour pour les
discussions qu'il y a pour intégrer
l'Ukraine aujourd'hui à l'Union
européenne il va falloir qu'on apporte
des réponses ce sera pareil pour l'UTAN
sinon l'Ukraine perdra la guerre et et
on ne peut pas faire en sorte
aujourd'hui que l'Ukraine perde la
guerre parce que sinon ça ne s'arrêtera
pas là une question de Vincent laamijour
mais avant j'ai une question par qui
nous a été posée par
monsieur laberur Dr RCF la Russie a
annoncé augmenter son budget militaire
de 70 % pour 2024 et semble pleinement
engagé dans une économie de guerre côté
européen estimez-vous que l'économie de
guerre voulue notamment par le Pr est
réellement enclenché je pense avoir
partiellement répondu à cette question
quand j'ai fait mon rapport sur sur la
Russie pardon à l'Assemblée
parlementaire de l'OTAN il y a 3 ans on
estimait le
budget russe de la Défense à l'époque je
crois C 60 milliards de dollars enfin
voilà mais le budget réel c'était
environ 200 milliards de dollars
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait il y a une
grosse partie des budgets qui étaient
détournés les budgets de l'éducation des
budgets de la culture et cetera qui
étaient détournés pour s'orienter vers
vers la défense aujourd'hui il y a
ouvertement une augmentation
significative du budget il y a une
grosse partie du PIB on parle de la
quasiment la moitié enfin je je parle
sous contrôle mais c'est ce qu'on entend
du PIB qui serait consacré aujourd'hui à
à à l'armée enfin en tout cas la
reconstitution du de l'industrie de
défense donc évidemment ils produisent
beaucoup on nous dit que en terme d'obut
de 155 ils en auraient fabriqué 1 9
millions en 2023 ça donne une idée de ça
permet de comparer avec ce que nous
fabriquons nous-mêmes donc euh je ne
dénis en aucune manière au président de
la République la volonté de d'accélérer
le processus et de faire en sorte qu'on
se réarme et ça c'est une évidence jeux
dire personne ici ne peut nier que le
budget de la défense a augmenté que les
trajectoires budgétaires depuis 2018 ont
été tenu et c'est quand même ça faisait
longtemps que ça n'avait pas été fait
que le budget a doublé entre 2017 et
2023 et ça personne ne peut le nier
c'est une évidence absolue mais comme je
le disais tout à l'heure les mots ont un
sens et parler d'économie de guerre pour
moi l'économie de guerre pendant la
pendant la la guerre de 39 45 c'était 30
% du budget américain qui était consacré
à la défense c'était des réquisitions
d'entreprise c'était des réquisitions de
personnel c'était une une économie dans
sa totalité qui était consacré euh à la
production de guerre pour gagner la
guerre aujourd'hui on ne peut pas
vraiment dire qu'en France on est mis
les moyens pour gagner pour pour pour
pour mettre en œuvre une économie de
guerre au sens litté du terme
donc est-ce que estimez-vous que
l'économie de guerre voulue par le
président de la République est
régellement enclenché je serai tenté de
dire non en tout cas si on veut parler
d'économie de guerre ce qu'il a mis en
place c'est une accélération des
productions une augmentation des
cadences quand c'est possible et cetera
et cetera mais c'est pas une économie de
guerre au sens au sens que que que enfin
au sens littéral du
terme vous disiez que l'économie supp
des réquisitions de personnel et C et
que vous vous ne demandiez pas ça mais
alors quelle serait l'économie de guerre
dans laquelle on devrait rentrer mais on
n pas for on n pas dit qu'on voulait je
dénie enfin je je dis que ce n'est pas
le terme approprié aujourd'hui la France
est pas en guerre
euh c'est exactement comme quand le
président de la République Hollande
disait en 2014 la France est en guerre
et moi j'avais dit la même chose les mot
ont un sens faisons attention à ce qu'on
dit les Parisiens sont au terrasses de
café la France n'est pas en guerre donc
aujourd'hui ce qu'on doit faire c'est
être un allé exemplaire clair c'est
avoir une capacité de production euh qui
nous permett de de d'être suffisamment à
la hauteur de la situation euh mais
avoir une capacité de production de
200000 de de 20000 pardon au but de 155
par an c'est être très loin d'être à la
hauteur de la situation donc entre
l'économie de guerre et une capacité de
production plus importante il y a quand
même il y a de la marge euh voilà donc
en revanche je réponds juste à la
question sur est-ce qu'on est est-ce
qu'on a enclenché l'économie du Guer je
dis non pour moi c'est un une une un
abus de langage
il avait Vincent qui avit vincentour qui
av
je vous en prie Paul gogo je suis
journaliste indépendant et je voulais
vous demander si les parlementaires
notamment Ukrainiens que vous avez
rencontré ou responsables politique vous
ont parlé de la présidentielle russe et
de la situation dans laquelle l'Occident
va se retrouver de reconnaître ou pas la
réélection de Vladimir
Poutine sachant que je il y a une
position certainement qu'onetrouvera en
Occident qui consistera à dire si on
veut pouvoir négocier discuter plus tard
obligé de reconnaître au moins un
demi-mot euh c'est peut-être même un
débat que vous avez au Sénat et je
voulais je me demandaer oui si si on
vous avait fait part de cette question
de cette problématique notamment en
Ukraine et au passage si jamais vous
l'un d'entre vous veut nous la raconter
vous vous avez un peu attisé ma
curiosité tout à l'heure sur votre
rencontre les conditions de votre
rencontre avec le responsable du
renseignement ukrainien si quelqu'un
veut nous raconter l'anecdote je suis
preneur sur
le sur le comment dire sur l'élection de
Vladimir Poutine oui c'est des questions
qu'on a abordé mais souvent avec le
sourire parce qu'en fait ça il n'y a
aucun doute dans l'esprit de personne en
le système démocratique russe éant ce
qu'il est je pense que l'élection de
Poutine ça dépend si elle sera à trois
chiffres ou à ou à ou à deux chiffres et
demi avant la virgule de 100 donc ça
pose pas de enfin a on en a parlé parce
que parce qu'évidemment c'est un élément
c'est un
élément du débat mais voilà par contre
sur la aissance même de l'élection
Vladimir Poutine je vous avoue très
honnêtement qu'on n pas allé jusqu'à se
poser cette question là moi en tout cas
ça m'a pas répond vasy je t'en prie je
crois que un des mots que vous avez
prononcé c'est négociation je crois dans
dans votre question un moment enfin
perspective et cet moi j'aimerais vous
partager je pense le sentiment partagé
également par par mes collègues c'est
que si vous voulez quand quand on
revient
d'Ukraine et que l'on voit si vous
voulez il y a les y a ce que l'on s dans
le regard le regard le langage
l'attitude de nos
interlocuteurs tout converge vers des
femmes des hommes qui sont en guerre
pour reconquérir la totalité de leur
territoire et c'est d'une
puissance qui est celle d'un pays en
guerre et qui ne doute
pas je je veux partager ça avec vous
parce
que vu de enfin en tout cas avant d'y
aller si vous voulez j'avais pas perçu
la la la la
combativité avec laquelle les Ukrainiens
sont engagés dans ce conflit et je dois
vous dire que je suis revenu avec
vraiment de l'admiration pour la
convativité de ces gens qui sont des
patriotes qui veulent tout simplement
reconquérir le territoire qui est celui
de des frontières de leur pays et et et
et et l'absence de doute si vous voulez
c'est un sentiment extrêmement puissant
que j'ai ressenti chez tous les
interlocuteurs et je je pense que ça
doit être partagé et détermination cette
détermination et c'est c'est c'est en
allant sur place si vous voulez qu'on
revient avec cette conviction c'est pour
ça que quand j'entends ce mot vous voyez
par exemple là je je partage ça avec
vous pour vous montrer que euh vous
ne après un tel déplacement si vous
voulez sur place vous ne n'oseriez même
pas prononcer ce mot devant des gens non
mais c'est pour vous me donner le
sentiment plus le j'imagine que d'un
point de vu
politique ça
vaêtre faudra bien sortir de tout ça
mais que d'un point de vue politique
même peut-être au niveau d'Emmanuel
Macron quand Vladimir Poutine et et je
suis entièrement d'accord avec vous sur
les conditions de sa réélection mais
quand Vladimir Poutine dira voilà j'ai
été réélu qu'est-ce qu'on fait
maintenant ça peut je peux comprendre
que ça puisse être délicat pour certains
représentants politiques occidentaux de
dire bah non on ne le reconnaît pas et
du coup on se ferme un peu toutes les
possibilités de discuter éventuellement
avec lui un jour je tout en connaissant
évidemment les conditions de bon moi je
à titre personnel on n pas évoqué cette
question avec mes collègues mais moi je
vois pas enfin je pense que ce serait
enfin l'erreur ce serait de rompre tout
dialogue de toute façon il y a a a il y
a un moment donné oou un autre il faudra
où il faudra entrer en discussion par on
va pas on va pas non plus éternellement
j' l'espère en tout cas rester sur un
conflit comme celui-là même si on peut
très bien se retrouver dans une
situation à la coréenne où on pose une
frontière et où pendant 30 ans 40 ans 50
an il se passe plus rien ça pas à
exclure du tout mais en tout cas ce
qu'avait fait le président de la
République au départ en en en étant un
peu vilipandé d'ailleurs qui en essayant
de maintenir ce dialogue avec Vladimir
Poutine je pense que c'était important
euh parce qu'il y a que par le dialogue
qu'on s'en sort je dis toujours qu'avant
avant la guerre le dernier rempart avant
la guerre c'est la diplomatie et donc
aujourd'hui encore il a il y aura pas
d'autre solution que le dialogue donc il
faudra bien en passer par là après sur
la reconnaissance je vais pas
m'aventurer sur cette question parce que
de toute façon euh
il s'il est réélu ce qu' laisse quand
même assez peu de
doute il sera l'interlocuteur unique et
principal des de celles et ceux qui
voudront discuter avec lui donc qu'il
soit reconnu ou pas de toute façon il y
aura pas d'autres interlocuteur donc il
faudra bien qu' donné la discussion se
fasse moi je vois pas trop de moi je
vois pas d'enjeu enfin c'est c'est la
théorie du fait accompli il un moment
donné vous avez pas de pas trop de
discussion à voir peut-être sur
l'épisode que vous vous évoquz sur la
rencontre avec le le responsable du
renseignement ukrainien avant notre
départ à l'initiative de notre Président
nous avions rencontré l'ambassadeur
d'Ukraine à Paris et lorsque nous lui
posions la question sur la situation sur
le
front bien sûr éloigné de du front il
nous a répondu qu'il serait bien lors de
notre déplacement que nous puissions
éventuellement rencontrer le responsable
du du renseignement qui lui disposait
d'éléments certainement plus récents et
et mis à jour régulièrement et et dans
notre planning nous avions euh au cours
de des 3 jours que nous avons passé en
Ukraine un rendez-vous spécial mais qui
n'était pas stipulé de de façon précise
et nous avons dans un lieu tenu secret
jusqu'au dernier moment eu la chance de
rencontrer une des personnalités
ukrainiennes les plus protégées vous en
doutez d'Ukraine
euh qui a été qui a fait l'objet d'une
tentative
d'empoisonnement durant ces dernières
semaines lui et et sa famille et et nous
avons pu disposer comme l'évoqué notre
président d'éléments tout à fait récents
tout à fait objectifs et et tout à fait
intéressant y compris pour les
parlementaires que nous sommes sur sur
la situation réelle sur le fond sur la
capacité de mobilisation à la fois en en
en personnel mais aussi en matériel des
Russes et nous avons eu une idée assez
assez concrète de de l'évolution à la
fois des difficultés de la
contreoffensive ukrainienne mais aussi
des des capacités de de pénétration sur
certains secteurs des des forces russes
voilà
moi je souhaiterais partager également
un sentiment suite à cette réunion que
nous avons eu c'est c'est la confiance
des Ukrainiens auprès de quatre
parlementaires français qui nous ont
communiqué un certain nombre
d'informations extrêmement sensible et
qui montre combien ils estiment que la
France est à leur côté est un partenaire
fiable et
et je m'attendais pas forcément avant le
déplacement à ce on a accès à de tel un
tel niveau d'information donc c'est une
marque de confiance qui est aussi
exprimée par les Ukrainiens à l'égard de
la France je crois que c'est quelque
chose qui est c'est vraiment un discours
qui est revenu très souvent euh les
remerciements à la France et l'aide qui
est apporté le soutien qui est apporté
et tout à l'heure Jean-Marc le disait
sur la la position européenne il est
urgent de évidemment de clarifier les
chosose mais je pense que la France a a
en tout cas eu a eu et a un rôle en tout
cas au niveau Europe euréen qui est
apprécié et surtout la position de la
France elle est la position pardon elle
est elle est attendue c'està-dire que on
nous le redisait ce matin avec la
représentante de Chypre pour eux la
France c'est c'est le pays des droits de
l'homme c'est le pays qui s'est battu
pour la liberté dans le monde c'est
voilà et on a senti d'ailleurs c'est
assez je sais pas comment l'ont vécu mes
collègues mais ce matin on a eu cette
représentante du du Parlement qui est là
à Paris pendant de jours j'ai senti une
une une
détermination inro incroyable dans ces
dans ces propos qu'on a ressenti aussi à
Kief enfin c cette force cette puissance
je l'ai ressenti aussi à Kief on a senti
des on a senti des gens qui étaient
menacé parce que Chipre l' quand même
qu'on le veille ou non
euh j'ai ressenti titre personnel
exactement la même chose avec cette
femme qui m'a paru incroyable donc
donc c'était c'était assez assez assez
intéressant assez poignant j'ai j'ai une
question d'an Bauer Desch qui dit
qu'attendez-vous de l'Europe il y a des
projets groupés dans dans les drones
lancés par les Baltes des projets de
défense anti-aérienne lancé par
l'Allemagne et la France reste
semble-t-il de côté comment
interprétez-vous en ce l'annonce de tiré
breton d'un fond potentiel de 100
milliards d'euros
euh moi je pense pas qu'on reste de côté
je pense qu'il y a des initiatives qui
sont prises par le ministère par la DGA
pour mettre en relation des entreprises
françaises avec des des entreprises
ukrainiennes qui a un travail de fond
qui est fait sans forcément en faire une
communication régulière mais j'en veux
pour preuve la visite du ministre de la
de la défense ukrainien et et et le
déplacement demain qui va permettre de
de d'organiser une rencontre je l'avais
demandé au ministre et jeen suis très
heureux que ça se fasse avec les
entreprises qui ont aujourd'hui des
intérêts ou des véités d'intérêt sur
l'Ukraine et donc des choses se passent
des choses avancent
euh la la la la la difficulté
aujourd'hui c'est plus la la question
des financements de savoir comment on
peut utiliser les fonds européens qui
ont été déployés pour ça de la manière
la plus efficace possible euh mais je
pense que chacun fait enfin on on on
fait on fait des choses il y a des
choses qui sont qui avancent et je pense
que les industriels de ce point de
vue-là en tout cas ceux qui qui ceux qui
sont en Ukraine et qui expérimentent ou
qui déploient du matériel sont plutôt
satisfaits de la manière dont ça dont
les choses avancent et dont les choses
se se mettent en musique donc moi je je
suis pas du tout critique sur ce sujet
comment interprétez-vous l'annance de
tir breton d' fond potentiel de 100
milliards d'euros plutôt bien mais c'est
toujours on en revient exactement à la
question de tout à l'heure c'està-dire
que quand on fait des annonces il faut
pas que ce soit de la com euh parce que
potentiellement c'est 100 milliards
d'euros ils sont pris je crois alors je
pas sous contrôle mais sous sur le
déficit enfin sur sur le le le le
déficit européen enfin c'est c'est assez
complexe et je suis pas persuadé que
demain on arrive à à le faire à le faire
voter comme il le souhaite on a tiré
breton demain matin en audition ici au
Sénat donc ce sera l'occasion de
l'interroger sur sur les les les chances
de pouvoir aboutir mais euh de toute
façon c'est ce que je disais tout à
l'heure sur la question des munitions
quand on a parlé descalp tout ce qui est
annoncé qui va dans le sens d'une d'une
augmentation de l'aide qu'elle soit
européenne ou française ou euh à
l'Ukraine va dans le bon sens la seule
chose qu'il faut dont il faut se
préserver c'est les effets
d'annonce Vincent lamigon challenge euh
trois petites questions une de forme et
deux de fond euh celle de forme euh
est-ce que le rapport de a changé de de
titre parce que moi j'avais noté changé
de braquet ce qui était un peu plus fort
que le titre finalement
voilà et parce que je sais qu'il y a
beaucoup de pression en fait de
l'exécutif sur tout ce qui concerne
l'Ukraine pas sur nous notamment sur pas
du voilà la deuxième question était sur
une de vos préconisations qui est la
fabrication de matériel d'origine
française mais en
Ukraine est-ce que ça vous semble
possible opérationnellement est-ce que
ça ferait pas finalement des usines en
question des cibles facile et quel type
de de matériel pourra être fabriqué
là-bas et la deuxième question est sur
le la Pologne on a vu l'année dernière
que la Pologne avait fait de très très
grosses annonces une pour la Plô pour la
Corée du Sud avec des d'achat d'armement
massif l'autre pour les États-Unis
est-ce que avec le nouveau gouvernement
vous avez l'impression que la porte est
plus ouverte pour des achats européens
sinon français alors deux choses il y a
la question du matériel qui pourrait
être fabriqué en Ukraine alors moi je v
pas de de liste à la prê verre à fournir
mais par exemple sur les canons César
les tubes sont des choses qui
nécessitent évidemment une logistique
importante et qui qui peut parfaitement
être fabriqué là-bas et et surtout qui
est en forte demande parce qu'évidemment
quand on tire beaucoup de de coups
quotidiennement il faut il faut les les
réaliser les les changer assez
régulièrement donc par exemple mais il y
a il y a beaucoup d'autres choses après
sur les bombardements bah oui c'est un
pays en guerre donc je vous rappelle que
c un décret napoléonien qui avait fait
en sorte queon n'implante pas d'usine de
la de fabrication de d'armement à la
frontière allemande c'est la raison pour
laquelle dans l'est de la France et
notamment chez moi on a finalement très
peu d'industrie de la défense donc c'est
une c une certaine logique à ça mais il
y a des sujets sur lesquels il y a des
besoins et des besoins qui sont des
besoins assez redondants et puis après
il y a des y a aussi une espèce de pas
dire de contrat au 7 mais il y a en
quelque sorte des échanges de bon
procédés donc l'Ukraine continue de
fonctionner je sais on est allé à Kief
et moi ce qui m'a surprise ce qui a
surpris aussi nos collègues et ce qui a
surpris un certain nombre de nos
collègues ce matin quand on a montré des
photos de notre déplacement c'est que
c'est une ville qui vit normalement
c'est-à-dire que certains d'entre vous
j'imagine ils sont allés nous on n' pas
eu le sentiment d'être dans un pays en
guerre en dehors des alertes au aux
abris euh régulières mais qui sont
plutôt très bien maîtrisés par euh des
j'allais dire des une information
notamment par par application euh euh
spécifique plutôt bien faite on na pas
eu du tout le sentiment de se trouver
dans un pays en c'est assez paradoxal
quand même donc euh
oui il y a des choses il y a des risques
de bombardement mais il y a des il y a
des urgences aussi et puis après c'est
aussi la capacité de enfin je pense à
une entreprise en particulier qui
fabrique des petites ogives explosive
qui se voit euh commander euh une
quantité très très importante de ces
matériels par l'Ukraine euh il y en a
une partie qui va être fabriquée là-bas
mais de toute façon ils ont pas la
capacité de production donc ça il y en a
une grosse partie aussi qui sera
fabriquée en France si toutefois on
arrive à aboutir mais voilà donc je je
suis pas trop sur cette question pas
trop excuse-moi Vincent je sais plus la
deuxième question ah la Pologne oui la
Pologne alors la Pologne ça a été une
longue discussion qu'on a eu avec les
les autorités polonaises évidemment il y
a le seul le seul membre du parti du du
du du pils qui que qu'on a rencontré
c'est le secrétaire général de la
présidence qui est toujours en poste euh
qui a eu un discours qui nous a semblé
aller assez dans le dans le sens de ce
que de ce que souhaite le nouveau
gouvernement euh ce qui nous a
clairement été dit c'est ce qu'on a mis
dans le rapport c'est que euh les
contrats qui ont été vraisemblablement
euh signés en pas signés mais mis en
œuvre avec d'éventuels
euh fournisseurs de d'armes jusqu'à ce
présent sont des contrats cadres donc en
fait ils sont en train je pense de de
faire un peu un bilan de ce qui a été
signé pas signé et puis euh de voir
comment euh euh des négociations peuvent
être faites donc je pense que je pense
que la porte reste ouverte évidemment
elle elle n'a jamais peut-être été aussi
ouverte que ces derniers temps avec le
nouveau gouvernement qui a vraiment la
volonté euh on l'a senti comme ça en
tout cas de de de se de faire un un
180°gr vers l'Europe donc tant mieux
enfin je pense que c'est quelque chose
qu'il faut qu'on qu'on arrive à saisir
mais euh voilà par définition un contrat
4 c'est pas un contrat définitif donc
tous les espoirs sont permis pere sur la
Pologne sur la Pologne je t'en prie pas
trop tarder parce que alors on a
notamment rencontré après
le greégor shetina c'est le président de
la commission des affaires étrangères du
Sénat polonais donc il nous a bien
rappeler que l'objectif de passer de 3,9
% de PIB à 5 % de PIB pour la défense
serait maintenu évidemment ça interroge
quand en Europe de l'Ouest on arrive
péniblement à 2 % du produit intérieur
brut voilà et par ailleurs il y a tout
un enjeu sur la montée en puissance de
l'armée polonaise qui effectivement doit
passer à six divisions parce qu'il y a
un enjeu de recrutement avec une double
difficulté la première c'est le plein
emploi en Pologne le plein emploi
évidemment est un obstacle au
recrutement et la deuxième c'est la
natalité et donc en réalité il y a un
véritable enjeu pour pouvoir atteindre
l'objectif de recrutement et de
fidélisation dans cette montée en
puissance de l'armée polonaise et mais
mais l'objectif est là cas
juste un élément que je souhaitais
aborder qui a pas été évoqué peut-être
c'est la confiance qu'on fait aux
Ukrainiens pour respecter les valeurs
qui sont les nôtres ça vrai qu'on
pourrait toujours se poser la question
de se dire est-ce que c'est pas parce
que dans un conflit que il se tourne
vers vers nous vers l'Union européenne
il y a quelques éléments qui nous
laissent à penser me laissent à penser
qu'ils veulent vraiment faire le choix
de la démocratie de nos valeurs la façon
dont ils répondent aujourd'hui aux
demandes de l'Union européenne pour
pouvoir
l'intégrer la place des femmes on a
rencontré beaucoup de femmes alors pas
forcément celles qui sont plus haut des
responsabilités mais les femmes sont en
responsabilité en Ukraine
euh la question de la corruption je
pense qu'il y a un vrai travail qui est
fait aujourd'hui pour essayer de de
lutter contre la corruption dans ce pays
on sait que c'est un mal endémique et on
a souvent entendu les responsables
politiques nous dire que c'était pour
eux quelque chose de prioritaire et puis
peut-être un petit détail mais qui moi
pour moi nen était pas un c'est la
question du culte de la personnalité
vous n'avez pas de grand portrait de
zenenski dans la ville voilà je me dis
que par rapport à la Russie ça montre
une petite différence qui peut nous
inviter à leur faire confiance et puis
avec les Polonais on a aussi dans les
recommandations qu'on fait inviter les
autorités françaises à accueillir
davantage d'officiers polonais dans les
écoles de guerre françaises parce qu'on
se rend quand même bien compte que quand
il y a une acculturation à la à la à la
France ça a été longtemps le cas dans
les pays africains quand même c'est
moins le cas aujourd'hui il y a derrière
tout ça une coopération beaucoup plus
poussée d'un point de vue militaire
stratégique mais aussi surtout d'un
point de vue industriel donc l'idée
c'est vraiment de de là on est plus sur
l'Ukraine on est sur la Pologne mais on
y a quand même passé un peu de temps
l'idé c'est vraiment d'augmenter
d'améliorer ou de de renforcer en tout
cas no nos coopérations dans un diff
dans dans différents secteurs ça me ça
nous semble être un point
important
oui oui vous avez évoqué donc le myiam
le maire Fréquence protestante la radio
vous avez évoqué donc les les questions
des des munitions longuement est-ce que
pour les Ukrainiens il n'y a pas aussi
un un problème de de recrutement de
combattants est-ce qu'il y a pas ça a
été dit par mes collègues que Olivier
dire à moi mais oui on l'a évoqué ce
matin en présentant le le rapport devant
la commission
euh lors de notre rencontre avec le
responsable du du renseignement
ukrainien ce dernier faz état de la
capacité de mobilisation russe qui entre
mai et décembre a permis de mobiliser
plus de 200000 hommes 200000 hommes qui
viennent compenser bien sûr les les
pertes sur le front euh que certains
interlocuteurs on ont pu évaluer à à
près de 1000 hommes certains jours donc
vous voyez c'est environ 30000 hommes
par mois qui viennent au moins pour
partie compenser ses pertes la
problématique ukrainienne aujourd'hui
c'est que
euh les combattants qui sont au front 2
ans après sont les mêmes que ceux qui
sont arrivés dès le premier jour et que
le président l'évoquait lorsque l'on est
à Kief effectivement la vie paraît
normale mais lorsque vous croisez des
des gens dans la rue il n'y a pas de
jeunes entre 27 et 50 ans c'està-d que
tous les toutes les personnes de cette
tranche d'âge sont sur le front et sont
mobilisé depuis le premier jour et la
difficulté effectivement de
remobilisation des forces ukrainiennes
réside dans le fait de de retrouver
cette capacité humaine à aller sur le
front ce qui fera la différence c'est
tout ce qu'on a évoqué durant cette cet
échange c'est le matériel la haute
technologie et tout ce qui pourra
effectivement être apporté en terme
d'aide à l'Ukraine sil y a une dernière
question parce que vous a pas échappé
que les questions au gouvernement
étaient
obligatoire donc on va essayie d'y aller
c'est bon pour tout le monde bon en tout
cas merci
d'avoir accepté de vous déplacer pour
ceux qui sont venus et puis merci à ceux
qui sont en vision
d'avoir fait la la démarche de de
participer à cette conférence bonne
journée mercire
je y